pope francis has refused to accept the
resignation of one of germany's top
catholic bishops
of the handling of a sex abuse scandal
cardinal reinhardt marx
offered his resignation in a letter to
the pope last week
marx who is the bishop of munich said he
had a shared responsibility for what he
called
the catastrophe of sexual abuse by
clerics
marx is not accused of committing abuse
himself a study found that nearly 4 000
children
mostly boys were sexually assaulted by
german clergymen
between 1946 and 2014.
uw's religious affairs correspondent
martin guck joins us now for more on
this story martin put this into
perspective for us why has the pope
refused cardinal
marx's resignation
well i mean it's very hard to say why i
mean what are the reasons behind what is
quite clear
is that in terms of
you know what was a very very very uh
big public relations stunt we might call
it i mean it was really a
very big deal a week ago this can only
be read as a rebuke
in the sense that uh you know now we're
talking about offering a resignation
whereas of last week
it really looked like you know he was
really just presenting a resignation
closing
the door in a position of power now what
we have is the pope essentially saying
no i mean you're going to stay where
where you are
um of course hard to say why but
clearly it has a lot to do with
institutional integrity
so the game is clearly not at an end and
now it is for
cardinal marx essentially to say
something because this
obviously cannot be the last word so
what could be the next step then for the
archbishop of munich he's one of the
catholic church's most senior figures
and a known liberal cleric
it's it's really very very difficult to
say and we should underline that
everything here is
speculation i mean mainly because the
story i mean
is a pretty dramatic story and this is a
dramatic twist in an already dramatic
story
but i think that we can expect one of a
few things we can expect
simply marx to go back uh from where we
came from from where he came from
which is a prominent position and
continue his job without basically
addressing
uh the response of the pope that would
be very very strange particularly
because he's a very important public
figure
and because a lot of what he brought to
the table i mean what was including his
letter of resignation had a lot to do
with the sexual abuse scandal and
essentially a
the accusation of a broad cover-up the
next question would be whether he would
take a more
senior be offer a more senior position
to actually deal with the things
that he has expressed his satisfaction
with that is not something
that you know it's clear but that could
be one way in which the vatican tries to
essentially uh go over uh
the qualms and the reservations
expressed by marx in his
uh in his letter the other thing that
obviously is on the table as well
is a clear break within or a clear clear
tension within the catholic church of
germany in which a very very
conservative figure like
uh wilkie in in colin who has been under
great pressure has refused to resign and
marx who has not been accused of any
kind of uh
uh you know missteps or any kind of
abuse
has actually taken the resignation of
saying the state of the church
is such that the only way to actually
move forward is
for actually for me to resign so this
tension i think will be
brought back to to to be visible will be
brought back to
to the top of the agenda as far as does
this situation is that
is this a german problem or does it
point to a wider crisis of the catholic
church
well i mean last week the american the
american specialized media
uh was abbas with the question as to
what was next for colonel marx and what
was
he going to be offered obviously he's
not a household name
in the us or in the rest of the catholic
world in the way that it is in germany
because he's here also a fairly
important
public figure nonetheless he is a
powerhouse within the progressive and
reformist
wing of the church and he has a very
close relation with the pope and he has
a massive footprint in vatican politics
over the last
five or six years our religious affairs
correspondent martin guck there in
berlin
thank you martin you're welcome
you